Jesse what good is the federal
government in terms of regulations if
this can happen to people and you know
last time he appeared before Maxine
Waters committee she appeared to blow
him a kiss at the end of it she didn't
appear to she blew I saw consider the
benefit of the day well Maxine water's
not related blew that kiss that's why
the Attorney General
had to put out this fire because this
guy was on a rehab tour and every time
he opened his mouth he was humiliating
the Democrats he was humiliating Bill
Clinton the IRS Wall Street the SEC
everybody was in bed with this guy and
for a month and a half he went out and
talked more than fauci and exposed the
code and the code is I'm going to say
whatever the left wants me that wants to
hear and I'm going to shovel money down
their throat so they let me do what I
want you're not supposed to talk about
the code it's a silent code it's called
green washing woke washing whatever you
call it and that blows up the whole
system and it's kind of like bribery and
it's kind of like greasing politicians
but he put it out their way too
graphically so he had to go down he's
stole money from people and then he
donated it to the Democrats
so Biden had to bust his second biggest
Mega donor it was a pump and dump he was
pumping and dumping but the Democrats
pumped and dumped him they legitimized
him he's got his company's name on
Arenas he's up there with Bill and
celebrities now there's collateral
damage so he went down hard
you could see this fraud a mile away
Greg and I talk about this all the time
whether it's avenatti whether it's
Millet whether it's this guy whether
it's Sammy Sticky Fingers who's pinching
bags at every airport in the nation
it's a big advertisement for a scam
artist and we see it but you can't say
it because if you say it you're a bigot
if you say it you know like these types
of people so you can't talk about it but
and then the left they don't want to
hear it because they're getting rich off
it and they're getting you know good
press off of it so whatever now he wants
to get out of prison because they're not
giving him a vegan diet yeah listen
that's not going to get your bail
reduced he's a Flight Risk already you
have to have colon cancer or something
like that because you don't like the
food sorry you're gonna have to stay in
jail with the some bohemian
Knuckleheads whatever they're in just
two weeks ago he was in front of a big
New York Times audience being
interviewed and the audience was
laughing when Sam Bateman freed was
making jokes about oh maybe I should my
lawyer said I shouldn't do this and they
thought it was so funny how quickly the
tide has turned Dana Yes red tide yes I
just wish that whatever wherever he is
right now give him some long pants
I just have seen I've seen his knees
more than I've seen my own these big
meaty hooks you know it's just like
sitting there with shorts I mean these
slightly better dressed than John
fetterman but I won't go that far the
timing is suspicious you know before he
sings he gets arrested if he ends up
dead in jail we'll know one thing that
he definitely swindled Hillary Clinton
[Laughter]
you know there are these red flags but
one of the red flags I'm sorry we got to
talk about how people look yeah okay you
can judge a book by its cover you
brought up Sam Brinton never should have
got a job I mean this guy look at him he
has the voice of a creepy wind-up doll
have you ever listened to them he looks
like one of the Forgotten Three Stooges
if he transitions perhaps he could be on
The View he's just it just it's just a
lesson and I'll reiterate what you said
it's a it's a lesson for everyone think
about the celebrities that sold this guy
yeah oh will they get sued they should
because they push this Tom Brady they
are except for Tom Brady
he's an American hero but anyway uh it's
a virtue signaling or compassionate
investing is usually a cynical cover and
this is why my theory is that
Republicans fall for this less than
Democrats because we you can't sucker
people that know economics into a bad
deal I won't even be tricked into a good
deal like I'm still not doing the 401K
until I see until I see some real
results the mattress must be really
stuck well that mattress it's it's
getting up there yeah without gold yes
yeah thank you William Devane